وصل المعارك الضاريه المتواصله في مختلف
جبهات اوكرانيا تبرز معركه باخمود كجبها
رئيسيه بالنسبه للجانبين فبقدري ما يرغب
الاوكرانيون في ابقائها تحت سيطرتهم بقدر
ما يطمح الروس الى دخولها صحيفه الاستوري
جورنال الامريكيه وصفت ان المعركه معركه
بخبط في شركه اوكرانيا ماتت اختبارات
حاسما لافاق موسكو العسكري تعد المعركات
في بحر هانا خاصه لقائد العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا الجنرال
سيرجينا الذي وعد بتحقيق تقدم من ملموس
هذا في الوقت الذي قال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه
ليست لها اهميه استراتيجيه بقدر ما لها من
اهميه النفسيه
للاوكرانيين والروس
معا
عموما دعونا نتعرف على اهميه هذه المدينه
ولماذا تعد اختبار حاسبا لكل طرف جغرافيا
باخ متقع على ضفتين نهر
شماليه مقاطعه دونيسك في اقليم دومباس
شرقي اوكرانيا تبلغ مساحه المدينه 41 كم
وصل عدد سكانها الى سبعين الف سنه قبل
الحرب بسبب الحرب فره 90% منهم وقال لحاكم
الموالي لاوكرانيا تكمن اهميه هذه المنطقه
بالنسبه للجانب الروسي في كونها البوابه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه شبه الوحيده لتقدم
قواتها في عمق منطقه تونس اما بالنسبه
للدفاع عن باقي مدن تونس كما انها تستغلها
لتوجيه ضربات نحو المواقع الروسيه في
الاجزاء الخاضعه لسيطرتهم بما فيها مدينه